Huge News Day, but the first a correction
people have been asking for more corrections.
So I figure I should make a few more mistakes
to have stuff
to correct. Right. Uh, yesterday I said that
Donald Trump's trillion dollar 2019 deficit
was a record. I should have clarified a record
for his administration. Not An all time record.
Uh, okay. There is a Minnesota congresswoman
named Ayllon Omar, who was born in Somalia,
uh, and is now an American citizen and a member
of Congress as well. And Donald Trump mentioned
her during his latest Mag, a rally in Greenville,
South Carolina, North Carolina rather yesterday
and the crowd of Trumpists immediately started
chanting, send her back, send her back, presumably
I guess to Somalia. Let's take a look in Ellison
[inaudible]. You talked about the evil Israel.
Trump had said a few things about, or right
before this that she looks down on Americans.
Something about, she blamed the u s for what's
going on in Venezuela, I believe. Although
maybe that was via tweet and the reaction
of the crowd is send her back to I guess a
reference to Trump's tweet from over the weekend
to her quote, original country and notably,
or maybe not notably, Donald Trump doesn't
react and you should see the defenses to this
from the Trumpists online. The main two defenses
I've seen are number one, Trump didn't react
and say, send her back. Therefore he has no
guilt whatsoever in this entire thing. Of
course, the silent complicity really does
says a lot, say a lot, and then number two
defense that I heard is, this isn't literal.
It's not literally sent her back. No Republican
literally wants to send her back there just
saying, we're Republicans and she's a Democrat
and we don't like Democrats. It's just partisan
bickering with a sort of hyperbolic statement
like send her back. Now the normal reaction
from a president of the United States when
a crowd starts chanting that an American citizen
should be sent back to a different country
should be how John McCain reacted during the
2008 presidential campaign against Barack
Obama. When a woman at one of his events said,
Obama is an a rab. Remember this?
I got to ask you a question. I don't not believing
I can't trust Obama. I have read about him
and he's not, he's not. He's a, um, he's an
Arab. He is not,
no, no ma'am. No ma'am. No ma'am. He's a,
he's a, he's a decent family man. Citizen
that I just happened to have disagreements
with on, on fundamental issues. And that's
what this campaign is all about now. Yes.
If you're saying, well, what about reacting
and saying it's not a bad thing to be an Arab.
Uh, yes, John McCain didn't do that, but at
least he did sort of immediately short circuit
this woman's delusions. But that was not Donald
Trump's reaction. Naturally, as you can tell,
as you can tell from the video, as you could
probably predict, if I said to you a crowd
chanted, send her back about Alon Omar, how
do you think Trump reacted? I don't think
anyone would say, oh, I'm sure he told the
crowd, no, no, no. She's an American citizen.
So this is now actually getting to the point
where it does sound like, and it does look
like the environment in some of the worst
authoritarian regimes that the history of
the world has ever known.
The anti-democratic police state houses of
horrors that we've seen over the last couple
of hundred years on planet earth. And this
is simply not what the United States was supposed
to be. I'll be really upfront with you guys
so that everybody understands this clearly.
You don't have to like Elon Omar or agree
with her on every idea to recognize that this
is simply unacceptable and this may even be
a backfire in some sense for Donald Trump
in terms of his war with the so called squad,
these four ethnic minority congresswoman who
are now getting a ton of attention because
there's been a lot of back and forth about
how the squad is polling and Donald Trump
completely misread a pole. There was a pole
that only talked to, I believe it was white
people with under two years of college or
something like that. And they don't like these
four women and it's like, wow, big, big surprise.
But if you step back a little bit, these are
not the most popular members of Congress nationally.
Now. All that really matters for their reelection
is obviously within their districts, but it's
not completely clear to me that Donald Trump
isn't actually helping the favorite favoribility
of at least some of these four ethnic minority,
female congress women by what he's doing.
Now. That being said, a lot of people simply
haven't heard of these women at all. Uh, and
simply becoming aware of the fact that there
are these four congress women is probably
good for them and not particularly good for
Donald Trump. But anyway, the point here is
this is not a drill. Okay? This has become
actual overt racism and xenophobia as a platform
by the Republican Party. And it is, as I told
you earlier this week, this is becoming Trump's
strategy for winning reelection. Okay. It's
not a bug.
It's a feature as I've been saying, it's not
something that they have to try to explain
away or distance themselves from their actually
embracing and understand that the defenses
here to the crowd chanting send her back were
to defend Donald Trump and say either Trump
didn't say it himself or merely to say this
is just politics. It's not literal. It's not
racist. It's not phobic. It's just politics.
It's saying we don't like hill on Omar's politics.
Remember they started by saying we're only
against illegal immigration. That was their
line for a bunch of you know, months or whatever.
A year Alano Marr came here legally, but they
say send her back. Even people from so-called
s whole countries can come here legally, but
they don't want them either and this was always
a ruse. That is the most important takeaway
from this entire thing. They claimed all along
to be against only illegal immigration, undocumented
immigration.
The reality is that it was a proactive plan
all along to push against non white immigration.
Even when it's illegal period. We can't stand
for it. We shouldn't stand for it. They see
this as a feature and not a bug. So the only
path forward is to remove every single one
of these people from elected office up to
and including Donald Trump. I don't know if
we're going to do it. I am very, very skeptical
of the success chances that removing Donald
Trump, I hope I'm wrong, but I don't think
it's looking particularly good at
this
point
in time.